[Musique]
bien dans le débat sur france 24 34e
jour de guerre en ukraine des
pourparlers russo ukrainiens ont eu lieu
à istanbul en turquie le ministre turc
des affaires étrangères a salué les
progrès les plus significatifs depuis le
début du conflit at il dit ces
pourparlers ouvrirait la voie à une
rencontre entre poutine et zeen ce qui
selon la délégation russe washington au
contraire ne voit pas de signe de
réelles sérieux de la russie dans les
discussions la turquie se targue en tout
cas depuis le début de la guerre de ne
pas être aligné sur l'occident un tweet
de ghassan salamé politologue ancien
envoyé spécial de l'onu a fait réagir
les plus tôt ce faire l'unité retrouvée
de l'occident va de pair avec sa
relative solitude partout ailleurs on
observe un mélange étonnant de
réticences de non-alignement
d'incompréhension d'indifférence d'un
rien de schadenfreude et parfois de
franche hostilité l'unité de l'occident
va-t-elle de pair avec son isolement
c'est vraiment la question qu'on se pose
ce soir qui sont finalement ces pays
dits non-alignés à commencer par la
turquie mais aussi l'inde l'egypte
l'afrique du sud ou encore israël
formule-t-il un bloc à quoi joue la
chine l'occident isolés on en discute
avec mes invités j'ai peur d'avoir à mes
côtés francis laloupo bonsoir
journaliste indépendant éditorialistes
enseignants géopolitique hauteur de
blues démocratique
1990 2020 c'est à paraître le 7 avril
chez écarte à la bienvenue à vous en
face de vous dominique moisi et bong -
esi pardon j'ai appris merci d'être avec
nous ce soir conseiller spécial à
l'institut montaigne hauteur du nouveau
déséquilibre du monde et c'est aux
éditions de l'observatoire pascal
boniface bonsoir le recteur de l'iris
votre dernier livre parce qu'on m'a
panneauté alesi alors 50 d'idées reçues
sur l'état du monde 50 idées reçues sur
l'état du monde et c'est chez armand
colin armand colin bienvenue à vous
pascal boniface en face de vous joseph
boillot bonsoir économiste spécialiste
des brics et puis membre du cercle
cyclope un cercle d'espère d'experts sur
l'evolution des grands marchés bienvenue
à vous nous allons avoir avec nous tout
au long de cette émission ludovic de
foucauld notre correspondant à istanbul
d'howick bonsoir justement on y va tout
de suite en turquie parce que c'était un
peu à l'aise pendant cette journée
puisque ardoines a fait un discours
juste avant ces fameuses discussions
entre ukrainiens et russes des
discussions qui ont eu lieu au niveau
ministériel
la turquie se présente comme anti
occidental alors qu'elle fait partie de
l'otan ludovic
oui bonsoir savani bonsoir à tous
effectivement c'est la position délicate
de la turquie qu'elle a depuis le début
de ce conflit et qui requiert évidemment
un sens certain de l'equilibre la
turquie a pris position mais ne prend
pas parti elle a choisi de ne pas
choisir le ne veut renoncer à aucune de
ces amitiés parce que c'est le mot qui
est utilisée par le président r douane
vous l'avez dit il était là ce matin au
palais de dolmabahce d'istanbul pour
accueillir les deux délégations et à la
fin de son allocution il a demandé aux
deux délégations de transmettre de sa
part à ces deux chers amis et voisins
les présidents et les skis et poutine
ses meilleurs sentiments la turquie
s'entend bien avec les deux présidents
avec les deux pays alors bien sûr la
turquie est membre de l'otan elles mêmes
le pilier sud de l'otan et elle
communique beaucoup sur le fait qu'elle
serait même un meilleur membre de l'otan
que d'autres membres de l'otan elle
rappelle très régulièrement qu'elle a
plus qu elle a un contingent plus
important en termes d'hommes dans l'otan
fin le plus important après les états
unis la turquie a vendu des drones armés
bayraktar tb de à l'ukraine des drones
armés qui sont d'ailleurs propulsé par
des moteurs
ukrainien la turquie qui était même
prête à monter des usines de maintenance
et de coproduction avec l'ukraine sur le
sol ukrainien la turquie qui a fermé le
bosphore aux navires de guerre et qui en
cela a accédé à une requête de l'ukraine
donc la turquie résolument dans le camp
occidental
sauf que non puisque la turquie ne
participe pas aux sanctions contre la
russie n'a pas fermé son espace aérien à
l'aviation russe et continue d'avoir en
tout cas au niveau présidentiel une
excellente relation
un autre raid j'étais hyper douanes et
la demi-heure poutine alors vous parler
d' anti occidentalisme de la turquie
dans le discours d'erdogan c'est pas
toujours aussi évident mais c'est vrai
que dans son camp dans son propre
gouvernement il ya ce qu'on pourrait
appeler en anglais des hardes liner
c'est le cas par exemple du ministre de
l'intérieur souleiman sol où il ya des
discours extrêmement hostile vis-à-vis
de l'occident l'occident qui serait
responsable de tous les maux de la terre
il ya deux choses en fait il ya
l'occident des stabilisateurs et c'est
vraiment une
une idée qui est extrêmement répandu
dans l'opinion publique turque y compris
vis-à-vis du conflit en ukraine quand on
parle aux à des turcs ici à propos de ce
conflit on se rend compte que pour eux
en fait l'ukraine a bien cherché que
zelensky en fait accru l'occident a
provoqué la russie en étant encouragés
en cela par les occidentaux et qui s'est
fait berner et qu'on ne peut pas faire
confiance aux occidentaux parce que
c'est toujours ce qu'ils font ou qu'ils
font leur nez givet à gros traits
évidemment mais il y à de l'instabilité
de la déstabilisation donc l'occident
des stabilisateurs et l'occident
décadent c'est aussi quelque chose qui
revient extrêmement souvent dans le
discours de serre diners comme disait
comme souleymane salou l'occident
décadent l'occident féministe lgbt
homosexuels etc toutes ces idées
subversives qui n'aurait jamais existé
ou qui n'étaient jamais présente en
turquie mais qui existent seulement à
cause des tentatives encore une fois
déstabilisation de l'occident donc c'est
avec ce genre d'opinion publique et
d'idées répandu dans la société que le
président r douane doit aussi composer
il doit composer avec cela depuis car
justement ils sont il ya plusieurs pays
qui sont un peu sur ce fil diplomatique
on va faire un point tout d'abord avec
ce module de france télévisions enjeux
de pouvoir et on en parle ensuite ils
restent sur le fil
des dirigeants de pays qui se veulent
notre ou semble hésiter entre la russie
et l'ukraine
[Musique]
enjeu de pouvoir sur le subtil numéro
d'équilibriste de certaines puissances
une neutralité qui peut paraître
surprenante pour narendra modi premier
ministre de l'inde plus grande
démocratie du monde mais dépendante de
moscou pour son armement porte avions
tanks avions de chasse jusqu'à 70% de
l'arsenal militaire indien vient de la
russie et ce n'est pas tout l'inde
achète aussi en ce moment des millions
de barils de pétrole russe à prix cassés
ne pas se fâcher avec moscou c'est ce
que veut aussi naftali bennett
le premier ministre israélien
notamment parce que la russie est
présente militairement syrie qu il y
avait un gentleman agreement en quelque
sorte entre moscou et et les israéliens
l'israélien laissait les virus et les
iraniens d'ailleurs faire ce qu'il
voulait pendant la guerre civile
syrienne dont il ne touche pas au régime
de bachar al assad moyennant quoi les
russes laissait les isréliens frapper
les installations militaires iraniennes
au sud de la syrie
résultat israël le livre aucune arme à
l'ukraine et ne s'associe pas aux
sanctions contre moscou
exactement comme le président turc
erdogan
certes bien présent sur la photo de
famille de l'otan dont la turquie est
membre mais projeté deux belligérants le
pays veut jouer un rôle particulier
pas seulement une position plutôt neutre
mais aussi d'essayer de récupérer un
rôle de négociateur dans ce conflit
pourrait devenir intéressant
il ya aussi ceux qui espèrent sans doute
tirer profit de la crise comme le
dirigeant dubaï qui voit affluer sur son
territoire des oligarques russes pressé
d'y placer leur fortune pour échapper
aux sanctions occidentales
mais de tous ces pays c'est la chine çi
jean ping qui pourraient avoir le plus
d'influencé dans quelle mesure aider
moscou face aux sanctions quelles leçons
tirez pour taiwan
la chine assure toujours ne vouloir
qu'une seule chose une désescalade du
conflit entre la russie et l'ukraine
pascal boniface pourquoi l'occident ce
site il un tel rejet parce que les
autres pays pense qu'il veut dominer le
monde qu'il veut imposer ses valeurs sa
loi et qu'il y a une réticence de plus
en plus forte à l'accepter parce que le
monde n'est plus l'occident a perdu le
monopole de la puissance qu'il avait et
de temps en temps il pense qu'il peut
toujours avoir ce monopole et ils
veulent imposer aux autres et donc on
voit dans la diversité des pays qui ont
été cités on peut en citer beaucoup
d'autres un refus à refus de dire oui
peut-être et il ya deux votes
reconnaître que la russie a fait une
agression et l'a condamné c'est ok mais
suivre l'occident dans les sanctions
c'est différent parce que tous ces pays
ne veulent pas apparaître comme suiviste
par rapport à l'occident et disons par
rapport aux états unis jean joseph
boillot les brics a en tout cas non ne
sont pas vraiment enfin ils sont restés
en bloc finalement un personnage et
parce que brésil inde chine russie et à
visionner et afrique du sud représentant
le continent on pensait que il ya deux
ans l'inde de moody aller glisser vers
la cua de les états unis et ses terrains
il y avait des contradictions internes
tout à fait entre la chine l'inde la
russie mais mais c'est normal la
contraction fait partie de la vie
intégrante de la géopolitique est ce qu
on a vu quand même tout d'un coup c'est
que ce groupe des géants 40% de la
population du monde c'est pas rien
40% la population du monde et 6 mai
l'afrique qui a présenté par l'afrique
du sud remontent à 60% elle a réussi
c'est incroyable sur cette affaire-là ce
que des et pascal boniface elle a réussi
à s'unir non pas sur le rejet de
l'occident je crois pas que ce soit un
roger d'occident sur la vision que le
monde unipolaire a conduit à la guerre
le monde en développement ne veut pas de
la guerre y compris la chine aujourd'hui
c'est surtout pas son intérêt est donc
ils se sont retrouvés sur une posture
kessel de 1955 band on l'a 65 ans vous
reprenez c'est à peu près les mêmes
avaient pas erdogan à l'épreuve
effectivement et en afrique c'est encore
des colonies donc les pays africains
n'étaient pas très très représentés mais
ce n'est pas un projet l'occident voudra
du tout pas du tout je suis étonné de
voir qu'il ya il ya une salle et ce au
milieu c'est la sagesse de tous ces pays
là et puis il ya des extrêmes des
radicaux des deux côtés 1 c'est à dire
du côté russe était épouvantable ce qui
se passe et du côté occidental à ce que
dit justement monsieur salamé c'est à
dire que il ya une sorte de
radicalisation néo conservatrice et le
monde ne veux pas de cela le monde veut
de la paix et il veut se doter d'un
moyen de régler les différends d'une
façon qui soit la note ne soit pas
l'ingérence de la non-ingérence et qui
soit un économie mondiale équilibrée
vous avez vu tout d'un coup la zone
dollar implose ça c'est nouveau c'est
extrêmement important à suivre parce que
ce que les brics n'avait pas encore
réussi à faire il avait juste planter
quelques petites graines et bien tout
d'un coup ce conflit est l'occasion de
pays en roubles et en yuan en roupies et
ainsi de suite je suis surpris de voir
l'accélération qu'il ya dans ce
basculement du monde bascule envie de
francis laloupo alors c'est vrai que il
ya eu 35 pays qui se sont abstenus lors
du premier vote à l'assemblée générale
des nations unies le sénégal s'est
abstenu alors depuis d'ailleurs on va
écouter maquis ça il a un petit peu
changé de position vous avez vous
expliquer
c'est en appel qui s'adresse au monde
entier à l'ensemble des partenaires
l'ensemble des partenaires bilatéraux
qui doivent travailler avec l'afrique
avec le monde entier puisqu'il n'y a pas
que la plus belle qu'il subit vous avez
d'autres pays en développement qui n'ont
pas les mécanismes comme nous qui ont
besoin d'être soutenus dans cette phase
critique c'est pourquoi nous plaidons
pour la fin comme de la guerre en
ukraine et il faut tout faire pour
arrêter ce conflit afin que les
conséquences soient quand même maîtrisé
sur
selon compte
qu'ils se condamnent la guerre mais il
n'y a pas de sanctions ce n'est pas du
côté bloc occidental et dans de nombreux
pays d'afrique pas seulement au sénégal
on a parlé bien sûr de l'afrique du sud
aura d'autres s'étaient résorbées en
fait on a affaire à une forme de
schizophrénie et en même temps ce qu'on
pourrait qualifier de neutralité
opportunistes chez macky sall mais en
même temps c'est un peu le reflet d'une
position qui est largement partagé par
beaucoup de pays en afrique d'un côté
macky sall s'est abstenu a fait au nom
de son pays du sénégal est par ailleurs
il faut rappeler que macky sall est
actuellement président de l'union
africaine en exercice devenu africaine
et à trois composantes de l'union
africaine et d'esprit même plutôt un
soutien à l'intégrité territoriale de
l'ukraine et là on entend effectivement
et macky sall qui finalement résume tous
non non non nous sommes un continent qui
doit travailler avec tous les autres
sans exclusive alors ce set une position
extrêmement difficile mais ça reflète au
fond la diversité des identités
politiques du continent africain c'est
quand on observe le vote de l'assemblée
générale de l'onu on s'est beaucoup
étonné du fait que plusieurs pays
africains 17 seulement au fond se sont
abstenus la majorité des pays africains
vous avez 28 pays je sais qu'en quatre
ont voté en faveur de l'ukraine en
faveur de cette résolution mais c'est
vrai que l'arrivée des réfractaires bon
sénégal l'abstention a été diversement
appréciée mais en même temps quand vous
voyez les blancs qui sont constitués
vous avez une lecture politique
géopolitique africaine aujourd'hui avec
le bloc des pays qui sont acquis je
dirais on dit aujourd'hui à la cause
démocratique
vous avez la montée évidemment des
régimes autoritaires et puis vous avez
je dirais entre les deux n'ont pas une
zone grise mais un espace où se situent
de régimes hybrides et qui cherche
également à gérer leur alliance le mieux
possible vous avez cette configuration
qui montrent en réalité l'afrique tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui mais qui montre si
l'état du monde telles que ils se
présentent aujourd'hui face notamment à
ce conflit particulier dont nous parlons
qu'est ce que ça signifie dominique
moisi que la démocratie en fait ne fait
pas d'émules le camp démocratique le
camp occidental
j'aurai une lecture un peu différent
de ce qui a été dit jusqu'à présent je
repartirai du vote
le nombre de pays qui ont voté contre
les sanctions 5
est extrêmement faible et on trouve des
pays comme
le venezuela de chavez la corée du nord
etc le nombre de pays qui se sont
abstenus est beaucoup plus important
mais parmi eux des pays qui à priori
aurait dû soutenir la russie comme la
chine est comme l'inde et je pense donc
la particulière et bien sûr ils n'ont
pas dit il ils ne sont ils n'ont pas
voté contre alors pourquoi n'ont ils pas
voté contre joyet deux raisons majeures
la première c'est que ce conflit est un
des plus manichéen que nous connaissions
depuis très longtemps je dirais même il
ya vraiment un pays qui est agressé une
crème il ya un pays qui agressent la
russie il est difficile de soutenir la
russie lorsqu'elle elle viole le droit
international elles bombardent des
villes elles tuent des civils chaque
jour plus nombreux et donc il me semble
que il y à un calcul
géopolitique
réaliste de la part de chine ping de
mode y ait encore plus d'erdogan qui se
disent nous ne voulons pas être associée
avec la guerre de poutine et erdogan
aujourd'hui avec une très grande
habilité me semble se comporter comme le
général franco à la veille de la
deuxième guerre mondiale je ne veux pas
être du côté du vaincu
décrit comme si l'apprécierait cette
préférence mais si fish est ici parce qu
elle est l es l et elle correspond le au
fond de sa pensée chaque jour de faim et
leur côté du mal et du mal qui est venue
n'est pas non plus du côté du bien c'est
ce que vous dites finalement aujourd'hui
c'est foot il le grand méchant alors oui
c'est bien lui l'agresseur c'est clair
mais aussi un facteur additionnel
notamment pour la turquie et notamment
pour la chine
c'est de dire on peut pas non plus
soutenir quelqu'un qui reconnaît des
provinces des provinces sécessionnistes
qui pousse un peu parce qu'ils ont
problème kurde ou un problème de xing
gens de tibet et c est donc là les
choses ont été très claires leur bon il
ya d'autres pays qui ont aussi commis la
guerre est le bien le mal en 2003
c'était aussi y avait aussi ceux là non
mais aujourd'hui face à la grèce
justement vous parlez de l'agresseur
aujourd'hui le méchant clairement c'est
vladimir poutine ce n'est pas l'occident
non mais justement d'où la position qui
se veut une position équilibrée et là je
reprends ce qu'a dit dominique moïsi
cihak à la fois on condamne la russie
parce que c'est une agression d'un pays
qui ne lui a pas fait la guerre et qui a
aucune justification juridique ou
politique à cela mais en même temps on
ne va pas dans les bagages des états
unis les accidents taux qui d'une part
eux-mêmes ont parfois soutenu des
opérations militaires illégales et qui
font une sorte et qui mettent en avant
des valeurs universelles pour les
appliquer de façon sélective et
l'application la guerre en lybie etc
l'application sélective des valeurs
universelles avait quand même très
revient très souvent dans le discours
aussi bien le malt latine en afrique en
asie pour va dire finalement après c'est
pas notre affaire disons que l'agression
c'est notre affaire la rivalité
stratégique entre l'occident et les
ennemis de l'occident ce n'est pas notre
affaire c'est ça que paye un petit peu
justement l'occident francis laloupo ses
erreurs commises la guerre en irak dont
certains font le parallèle est
intéressant quand on parle de l'occident
parce que je me suis toujours demandé on
peut se le demander quel est le
périmètre géographique de l'occident où
commence l'occident et où se termine
oxydes encore une histoire de valeur
alors c'est d'abord je veux dire il ya
une question je dirai pas non plus
d'afrique par exemple l'occident
généralement quand on voit monter
aujourd'hui des ressentiments à
l'encontre de l'occident désigné
évidemment comme un fauteur de tous les
maux on pense essentiellement à l'europe
à la france derrière pour les pays
francophones et on pense aux états unis
alors est ce que le japon est un pays de
faisant partie de l'occident ou pas
alors donc ce périmètre est devenu fou
c'est vrai depuis plusieurs années avec
eux pendant la guerre froide ça semblait
évident évidente pas de l'occident y
avait des limitations géographiques en
même temps idéologique qui sont prêts à
peu près
à peu près disons cernable haut depuis 6
ans évidemment est devenue une concept
relativement floue et il faudrait
peut-être de le re définir si c'est en
termes de valeur attendue ce mois là
effectivement on peut mais il n'est pas
évident que d'ailleurs tous les pays qui
sont compris dans cet occident le
partage forcément les mêmes valeurs
puisqu'on voit aujourd'hui monté
notamment en europe quand même ce qu'on
appelle c'est fait ces régimes libéraux
qui chahutent quelques pas des valeurs
30 qui semblait a priori partagé par
tous les membres de l'union européenne
ce n'est pas moi le noeud monolithique
cm mais par contre quand même des axes
structurants alors dominique moïsi est
obsédé par axe démocratie non démocratie
le monde ne répond pas seulement à cela
la réponse truc n'ont rien de dramatique
qui est riche pauvre développé non
développés et ce qu'on voit c'est pour
ça que j'insiste sur bang bang donc
l'union soviétique était d'à côté les
états unis de l'autre à l'époque 28 pays
ensuite à l'âge d'or des non-alignés 128
p on dit ni l'un ni l'autre et moi ce
qui me frappe c'est non pas ce vote mais
c'est la façon dont ces sanctions sont
gérés dont on renvoie dos à dos un camp
contre un autre lapin meilleur que
l'autre pourquoi et bien parce que les
pays en ce moment en développement font
circuler partout le rappel de l'irak de
la syrie du yémen et y trouve qu'il ya
une inégalité une hymne equity qui est
en train de se développer donc je trouve
cet important de ré de trouver en tout
cas à l'échelle du monde et ce conflit
peut l'aider une sorte de synthèse entre
ce qui est l' axe des démocraties et la
de l'équité tant que le monde sera
inéquitable c'est ce qu'a dit quelqu'un
à l'onu c'était très juste il y aura des
guerres de cette ampleur là donc je
trouve que c'est que ces pays là kindy
phare de clarifier justement les choses
en parlant juste d'équité de me croiser
mais on a là deux de réponse la première
sur qu'est ce que l'occident est un pays
qui est passionnant face à cette guerre
c'est le japon le japon qui fermait qui
accepte pas
les étrangers soudain vient d'ouvrir ses
frontières aux réfugiés zueras ira à eux
l'ukrainien
nom est tout à fait aux réfugiés aux
réfugiés semaine en bleu aux réfugiés
parole aux réfugiés ukrainien de 2,2
deuxième point
je pense que
et ce qui me frappe et c'est un peu une
réponse à votre question c'est le
caractère sélectif des émotions
occidental c'est à dire que quand
j'écris une chronique pour dénoncer ce
qui se passe en ethiopie la guerre
contre le tigre et les les populations
civiles qui sont victimes des conditions
terribles de la guerre et de la famine
ça n'intéresse pas grand monde
en france donc c'est quoi de l'europe et
au centre ici si tu cites c'est une
référence culturelle
pourquoi les les ukrainiens sont des
européens ils sont la porte à côté on se
sent on se sent concernée mais même
d'une autre manière je le dis très
simplement légitime d'être plus concerné
par son voisin non non mais mais les ldl
je vous dis l'histoire ma petite fille
me dit grand père
quand je lui dis les rues sont envahies
les ukrainiens il me dit est ce que les
russes vont nous envahir aussi elle
connaît la carte de l'europe elle se dit
c'est pas si loin ça peut arriver et
donc je crois qu'il ya tout simplement 7
10 messieurs juste valeur certes limité
oui mais c'est justement cette façon
c'est enfin à agir ludovic al de ville
une part parce que les pays africains
ont bien vu aussi l'accueil réservé aux
étudiants africains qui ne pouvaient pas
sortir d'ukraine qui ont été mal reçue
en pologne et qui ont été discriminés et
donc ils voient ça effectivement et puis
le terme de sanction il est occidental
ces pays ont été les uns après les
autres sanctionné par l'occident et
obtient de sanction est appliquée tôt
mais ça fonctionne et du temps de
l'afrique du sud de l'apartheid c'est le
scénario était globale et c'était le
monde entier est tellement grand qu'il
n'était pas prêt jusqu ici c'est plutôt
l'occident qui a l'habitude de
sanctionner comme un maître d'école
sanctionne les élèves et tous ces pays
qui sont non occidentaux aient bien
réagi 110 ans c'est le principe même des
sanctions vous décider à la place des
autres vous pensez être les maîtres du
monde nous refusons cela et pour
répondre à la question et francis albou
bayani fillon géographique mais des pays
comme le japon ils sont pas occidentaux
géographiquement me sont stratégiquement
parce qu'ils ont des liens stratégiques
avec les états unis ils nous ont peut
lire tu réellement puisqu'ils ont une
culture politique pied démocratique
voilà à nouveau donc justement la
scission entre démocratie pas démocratie
villa poney jeux les pratiques et je
dois vous dire qu'elle est plus
japonaise que démocratique faudra qu'on
visite le répertoire de contentieux
ludovic de foucauld donc à istanbul
ludovic voulait réagir peut être c'est
un opportuniste finalement car doan
je pense qu'il ya quelque chose que
parfois du côté occidental quand on est
en europe de l'ouest quentin aux états
unis un accord il ya quelque chose qu'on
a un peu de mal à lire c'est que des
pays qui veulent ne pas s'aligner c'est
pas qu'ils sont pro russe mais c'est
qu'ils sont profondément méfiant
vis-à-vis de l'occident je vous citez
les résultats d'un sondage qui a été
fait ce mois-ci par l'institut métropole
en turquie alors c'est un institut
crédible parce que justement il
travaille répondant aux standards
occidentaux vont ouvrir on n'en sort pas
est la question c'est est-ce que selon
vous c'est une question posée aux turcs
est ce que selon vous on doit être
neutre on doit être pro russe on va être
compris craignant d'or ce dans ce
conflit 72 9 % des gens interrogés
veulent la neutralité oui c'est énorme
seulement 2 5 % veulent que la turquie
soit pro russe et 19,1 pour sens quand
même beaucoup plus dans le veulent
qu'elle soit propre craignait mais cette
idée que il faut être non alignés c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très prégnant
de très fort parce que il y à l'idée que
sinon on n'aurait pas d'avis et il y à
la vision d'une europe ici ça c'est
vraiment très très prégnant en turquie
la vision d'une europe qui en fait est
dirigé par des gens qui ne pensent plus
qu'ils ne pensent que parce qu'ils sont
contraints et parce qu'on leur dit de
penser ceci aiguille évidemment ce sont
les états unis qui sont toujours un
petit peu quand même le grand le grand
méchant dans la sphère et si vladimir
poutine aussi la vision d'un dealer
poutine qui respecte recep tayyip
erdogan est si importante ici c'est
parce que justement il voit en raid
j'étais hyper dont ils verraient en
réchappe t il perdre one quelqu'un qui
des fois avant tout les intérêts de son
pays et même s'il appartient à des
alliances il pense d'abord à son pays il
ne va pas ces lignes et parce qu'il ne
va pas faire automatiquement ce que les
états unis lui demander ça c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement
valoriser ici en turquie dominique moïsi
or justement peut-être réagir sur cette
cette idée cette perception en turquie
là on peut peut-être retrouver ses
lignes entre démocratie et régimes
autoritaires oui mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que il ya deux cent
mille russe à peu près
certainement plus aujourd'hui qu'ils ont
quitté la russie depuis le début de la
guerre ils ont fui un pays dans lequel
il ne se reconnaissait plus la plupart
d'entre eux sont en turquie à istanbul
parce qu'il trouve en turquie la
proximité est quand même un air de
liberté qu'il a qui a complètement
disparu en russie mais sur la question
démocratique ce qui est intéressant
c'est que quelle est la victime
collatérale
de l'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie
les populismes regardé en france il ya
un avant et un après 24 février pour
eric zemmour il y à regarder le
changement d'attitude radical de la
hongrie durban regardez là la
modification de comportement de la
pologne avant elle s'indignait des
diktats de bruxelles maintenant ça n'est
rien marc averse à lambres c'est
l'amiante par rapport à la menace par
rapport à la menace des chars russes
donc en fait il ya une réécriture dans
tout cela on se dit mais quand même il
ya un pays qui en envahi un autre avec
la plus grande brutalité
il est évident qu en afrique en amérique
latine il y à des valeurs universelles
et ça va bien au delà de l'opposition
entre démocratie et non démocratie c'est
les valeurs permis sa valeur justement
de leur ca permettent d'interpréter
aussi
l'abstention lors du vote à l'assemblée
générale de l'onu c'est que voilà la
plupart des pays africains soient en
train d'attacher à 7,1 principes comme
la non-ingérence
donc des prêts
à lise
évidemment difficile de soutenir un pays
qui est se comporte comme je devrais
ilonse impérialisme voilà un loyer ne
pas dire voilà
c'est la raison pratique on se
positionnait à la question c'est le lieu
d'insister un peu jeudi un suspect
contentieux parce qu'un poids pour le
sujet porte quand même si le contentieux
qui auraient éventuellement entre
l'occident une partie du monde que
reproche-t-on à l'occident il faut quand
même effectivement jédir se pencher là
dessus car corporation accident au vu
d'un free par exemple et ya le
contentieux de l'irak et qui n'a jamais
été vidés en réalité un la libye ensuite
la libye avait bien entendu on peut
également parler aujourd'hui de la
manière dont la question sécuritaire est
géré au sahel il ya un certain nombre de
contentieux accumulés et par exemple
pour les pays francophones en afrique il
ya toujours ce qu'on appelle les comptes
mal sur des de la colonisation et a
toujours je dirais 7 me il ya cette
difficulté ce que cette crispation
franco africaine qui perdure et il ya un
autre point qu'il faut souligner
puisqu'on parle de démocratie ou et des
régimes autoritaires c'est qu'on peut
mal et que les gens mains des comptes
mal sur le dé aussi de la guerre froide
mais que qu'ont fait les pays de vieille
démocratie où soutenir les démocraties
émergentes depuis trente ans quand elle
fait pour les renforcer et aujourd'hui
on peut faire les comptes évidemment
combien de régiment pour la démocratie
ce qui est clair c est fait
effectivement les pays africains enfin
est-ce qu'ils parlent par les pays
africains francophones plus l'aviation
s'éloigne plus les souvenirs de la
colonisation se rapproche un peu une
sorte de paradoxe parce que auparavant
la france 2 c'est niais le rappel et les
pays votaient comme un blog comme la
france l'avait dit ce n'est plus le cas
parce que des pays estime qu' ils ont
leur intérêt et qui n'ont pas à suivre
règlement et c'est vrai que dès le
départ moi j'avais averti il ya une
agression russe mais il faut pas que ce
réponse occidentales si on occidentale
is la réponse est qu'on a fait passer
principalement par l'otan on va perdre
du monde l'attend et joe biden
d'ailleurs sur la réponse de hollande je
pense que les états unis étaient
maintenant jeune avocat un changement de
régime ce qui est vraiment le chiffon
rouge pour tous les pays qui ne sont pas
occidentaux parce que le changement de
régime pour les séries c'est vu comme
positif on prend un pays dictatorial et
on a fait une démocratie les autres pays
du hockey irak afghanistan et libye donc
le changement de régime c'est vu comme
l'agression d'un pays occidental au nom
du bien collectif contre un pays plus
petit donc sur la dévolution immédiate
sur la voie là c'est important non pas
la position debout dit maudit comme
erdogan ce sont 20 de dictateur en
puissance ou xetra se parler les grands
re1 les grands démocrates ce qui
m'importe c'est la population indienne
avantage d'avoir une belle famille c'est
de savoir comment elle réagit il y as en
inde en inde un consensus très fort non
pas pour soutenir la russie du tout la
question donne on ne se pose pas pour ou
contre mais pour dire new world order je
vous avais dit le times of india
deux éléments deux éléments et c'est pas
les armes russes qui intéresse cette
population indienne c'est le souvenir
dramatique dramatique pour eux de ce qui
s'est passé en irak et en iran donc on
relève à langres est assez 8 romano
soldes ont soldé mauvais comptes du
passé c'étaient les grands alliés de
l'inde il fournissait le pétrole de
l'inde l'irak et l'iran et tout d'un
coup voilà le monde occidental a décidé
que et puis deuxièmement pour les un peu
plus vieux
1971 monsieur dominique moïsi c'est ce
qui s'est passé en pleine guerre du
pakistan les états unis interrompre
livraison dame à
indira gandhi et
complique énormément la guerre de l'inde
des habits de 7,1 des deux pas d'ici il
saura se souvenir est impérissable les
états unis et l'occident n'est pas
fiable un chef dont traître c'est un peu
ça vous dit de me noyer
nous
que l'occident et du sang sur la main et
des péchés et commis des erreurs
multiples en particulier sur le
continent africain c'est évidence
absolue et je crois que nous payons
aujourd'hui le prix de nos péchés
d'hyères maintenant il ya ce qui se
passe en ce moment même sur le terrain
c'est à dire qu'il y a le dirigeant d'un
grand pays une puissance responsable qui
brandit la menace
d'utiliser l'armé nucléaire et ça c'est
quand même quelque chose de fondamental
et ça ne suffit pas en tout cas à
solidifier ce camp ont souffert d'autres
ont mis en évidence avec la question
nucléaire est considéré comme un élément
clé dans les pays en développement mais
que ce qui revient en permanence en ce
moment c'est l'idée que si la russie
n'avait pas le nucléaire alors alors
elle aurait dû s'écraser devant l'otan
donc il y a de la part de toutes ces
puissances iran etc vous savez comme moi
une guerre avec l'occident qu'on le
veuille ou non c'est bien avec
l'occident sur la question de l'armé
nucléaire donc soit l'occident décide de
rejoindre le camp de ceux qui ne veulent
pas d'un nucléaire du tout le traité de
non-prolifération des armes nucléaires
que comme par hasard les cinq puissances
ont refusé mais s'ils ne le font pas
pourquoi les puissances comme la chine
experts moi ça m'a beaucoup frappé la
question du nucléaire et des battus dans
tous les pays du sud en ce moment est de
dire je ne peux pas réservé à l'occident
le monopole du nucléaire aux amoureux je
vous entends je vous entends très bien
d'abord la russie y est sauf preuve du
contraire un pays occidental
la population
sa piste un pays européen sur le plan
sur le plan de la culture c'est quand
même largement il met donc au pire une
époque si dans tales of the hard rock
c'est là que s'est terminé de célébrer
pendant c'est quand même c'est une chose
de dénoncer le comportement
de l'occident sur le nucléaire c'en est
une autre de dire mais au fond il a le
droit de brandir la menace de l'armé
nucléaire il a le droit de se comporter
comme tignes on perd ce ne sera en corée
du nord c'est vrai ce qu'analysent
assise non c'est moi je dis ça mais
comme ils ne le disent pas mais ils ne
disent pas l'un vers il vise l'occident
est hypocrite en accusant de les autres
de vouloir la pudeur de rigueur
nucléaire jeu notamment les indiens vous
savez comme moi les indiens ont été
condamnés c'est parce qu'elle avait brel
après midi face à l'iris et la ska qui
nous interpelle quand même c'est qu'on
doit réaliser qu'on ne domine plus le
monde et qu'il ne suffit pas que les
pays occidentaux se mettent d'accord
entre eux pour que tout le monde suive
mais ces votes doivent nous interpeller
sur le fait que le monde est devenu
divers que tout le monde ne pense pas la
même chose et qu'il faut mais si on la
russie larsen occident ou pas mais non
c'est pas l'occident donc ça n'est pas
le cas c'est un pays européens mais qui
n'est pas occidental puisque l'occident
et la russie se reconstruit pour un gain
froch l'un contre l'autre et que l'on
voit depuis déjà et que la russie estime
qu'elle était trahi par l'occident après
la fin l'implosion de l'union soviétique
que l'occident l'a maltraité alors
beaucoup de gens disent non c'est pas
vrai sauf que les russes en sont
convaincus donc le sinon et l'europe
pascal boniface ça n'est pas la même
chose non la non non c'est ça qui serait
intéressant est ce que l'occident et
l'europe c'est la même chose mais
l'europe fait partie de l'occident lui
en plus dur mais pas là aussi l'europe
occidentale
ça va au-delà l'europe orientale et de
est encore plus pro occidental que non
non révélé elle est au milieu c'est
l'europe des médias de la fameuse finale
dames il dénie à droite ni à gauche
alors j'ai habité pendant dix ans dans
ces pays là notamment demandé aux
polonais hélas un monde slave ce n'est
pas le monde occidental dans le monde
cela avait très particulier si les
critiques sur un plan géopolitique il
est difficile d'être l'ulpro rupture
dans la balle mais pas de temps pour y
vivre l'histoire de cette région du
monde est une histoire de l'antre 2 les
plus grands les plus grands analystes
notamment que vous connaissez qui ont
écrit sur l'antre 2 notamment le
hongroise oublié son nom lorsque je suis
arrivé à prague et que j'ai travaillé
sur la pologne là aussi j'ai été frappé
de ce que le problème justement de cette
zone du monde c'est ça qu'on veut pas
regarder c'est la géographie celle entre
eux
la chine du tout comme on va en parler
juste alors ludovic de foucauld juste un
mot justement cette distinction entre
europe et occident est ce que du côté
des tuyaux justement il ya eu cette
problématique en plus d'entrer dans
l'union européenne tout en étant dans le
camp occidental tout en restant donc
qu'est ce qu'on en dit là bas
non les turcs ne dirais pas qu'ils
appartiennent au camp occidental ou
qu'ils sont occidentaux dirait qu'ils
appartiennent à la rigueur au monde turc
mais je crois qu'il ya quelque chose
d'intéressant qui a été dit sur l'inde
et je crois qu'on peut faire un
rapprochement avec avec la turquie il ya
quand même un sentiment il ya un
ressentiment quand même un qui est très
prégnant dans la société turque il ya un
sentiment de revanche isme vis-à-vis de
l'occident il ya ici ce qu'on appelle le
syndrome de sèvres je n'ai pas trop
rentrer dans les détails mais enfin
c'est l'idée que les occidentaux en
l'occurrence les puissances européennes
à l'époque où lui à l'époque delà de la
première guerre mondiale ont cherché à
la chute de l'empiré ottoman à démembrer
complètement la terre que la turquie et
il a fallu un atatürk pour sauver le
pays et pour fixer le pays dans les
frontières qui sont les siennes
aujourd'hui et sans lui les européens
les français les britanniques auraient
complètement des membres et a démontré
la turquie il est urgent garde un
ressentiment vis-à-vis de ça et encore
une fois une méfiance très importante
vis-à-vis des puissances occidentales
donc il ya ya
ce revanchisme c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut vraiment prendre en compte surtout
de la part de pays qui ont été des
empires comme c'est le cas de la turquie
avec l' empire ottoman comme des pays
qui ont eu une place très importante
dans l'histoire et c'est d'ailleurs
systématique dans le discours du
président erdogan se revanchisme cette
façon de récupérer de retrouver la place
qui appartient à la turquie dans
l'histoire de faire partie des dix plus
grandes économies du monde d'ici 2023 de
faire partie de la champion's league des
nations c'est un terme qu'il utilise lui
même de retrouver la place de ces grands
ensembles dans l'histoire parce que au
fond à côté d'eux des pays comme la
france ou la grande-bretagne les
occidentaux en général sont en réalité
une anomalie historique parce qu'ils
apparaissent dans l'histoire ils
deviennent sinon de très tardivement et
pour un moment en fait assez court quand
on le met à l'échelle de plus grands
ensembles comme l'environnement comme la
chine comme l'inde
avec un regard historique plus plus long
francis laloupo donc une revanche c'est
aussi ce que veut prendre meilleures
poutines manifestement trois puissances
aujourd'hui anti occidental à l'oeuvre
sur le continent africain la turquie la
russie et la chine
la concurrence elle existe et comme
disait pascal boniface il faut prendre
en compte cette recomposition des pôles
de puissance aujourd'hui à la fois sur
la planète et dans des régions comme
quand tu veux comme l'afrique et ça
répond à votre question des cadres
occidentaux n'est pas plus isolé
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne l'étaient lors de
la guerre froide déjà pendant la guerre
froide rend compte et les alliances
aujourd'hui l'élément nouveau c'est
depuis une trentaine d'années les
nouvelles formes de concurrence et de
compétition notamment dans sur un
continent comme le continent africain
avec évidemment des nouveaux partenaires
grands partenaires comme la chine la
russie et la turquie bien entendu parce
que dans tout cela et je termine là
dessus il ya l'ombre portée quand même
de la chine qui avance de façon
peut-être être plus discrète moins
massives - voyousie direz vous que la
russie mais qui est présente fortement
massivement présentes et qui est faut le
rappeler aujourd'hui la le tas
autoritaire le plus puissant de toute
notre histoire contemporaine justement
pascal boniface la chine elle a passé un
accord avec vladimir poutine si jingping
vladimir poutine on ne sait pas très
bien on n'a jamais su très bien ce
qu'ils avaient dans cet accord un accord
commercial et militaire et au final elle
n'est pas véritablement dans le camp de
la demi-heure poutine non parce qu'une
fois encore elle n'est pas pour les
guerres elle a pas envie que
reconnaissent des provinces
sécessionnistes
mais ne veut pas que la russie tombe
parce que si la russie tomber ça serait
la victoire de l'occident états unis
donc elle ne veut pas soutenir jusqu'au
bout la russie parce que tout ceci la
gêne ça va gêner sa croissance
économique ça va augmenter le prix des
matières premières énergétiques
alimentaires et sont des postes
importants dans qu'elle n'aime pas le
désordre et la russie est venue mettre
du désordre dans un monde qui était déjà
suffisamment mais en même temps il n'est
pas pour que la russie soit tellement
puni que l'occident triomphe donc elle
essaye de soutenir suivant la russie
pour qu'elle ne coule pas mais pas trop
pour que le triomphera josée boileau
vous êtes frappe c'est un le
ressentiment de la population chinoise
là encore il faut pas oublier c'est des
choses très importantes pour pas que les
dirigeants sont pas complètement coupés
de leurs populations de même que poutine
n'est pas coupée de la population russe
il faudrait le répéter un peu plus de
côté chinois faille de la propagande oui
beaucoup non mais il est pas entièrement
coupée c'est devenu reste de mise elle
ne se serait pas 200 milles ça serait de
100 millions d'euros qui aurait quitté
le pays ce qui me frappe c'est la
population chinoise son neveu veut
profiter de sa prospérité elle a horreur
de la guerre et moi ce qui me frappe
c'est tout ce qui est en train de
circuler ils sont très touchés par les
ukrainiens beaucoup plus qu'on ne le
pense il ya une win une solidarité très
nettes mais en même temps ils ont un
sentiment que l'on cherche en réalité et
ça je suis désolé dominique moïsi mais
pour le dire derrière la russie
d'attaquer la chine c'est à dire qu'on
sait bien que la rivalité
géostratégique mondiale qui est en train
de se préparer c'est entre la chine et
des états les états unis et donc les
scribes a couru sur les réseaux sociaux
chinois c'est cette idée ils sont en
train de nous faire un coup de jarnac
donc c'est pas qu'on soutient la russie
c est ce qu a dit pascal boniface tout à
l'heure on ne veut pas qu'ils en
profitent pour affaiblir la chine mais
alors qu'est ce qui reste vision choisi
plusieurs choses alors je torino reste
deux minutes d'évasion en une minute
trente secondes je vous dirais le
premier point les grands vainqueurs à
très court terme de ce qui vient de se
passer en ukraine ce sont les taïwanais
parce que les chinois se disent c'est
peut-être pas si facile
d'envahir un autre pays ils résistent
ils ont un nationalisme très fort
deuxièmement je suis globalement
d'accord avec ce que disait pascal
boniface il ya une une ambivalence
structurelles chinoise d'un côté ils se
disent c'est pas mal
cette guerre entre la russie et le monde
occidental
accélère le processus de basculement du
monde vers l'asie ce sont les hommes
blancs qui se font la guerre c'est
l'asie qui va apparaître comme le grand
vainqueur de tout seul et non pas la
démocratie si à taïwan moi je dis dans
le maine-et-loire est très important
sarah va des cartes aussi en asie et je
pense qu'effectivement désormais la
stratégie chinoise devient sérieusement
comprend 6 à nouveau à votre confusion
dans cette confrontation qui est aussi
idéologique
parce que c'est quand même un pari qui
est lancée aussi aux démocraties je
pense que la fema sont des démocraties
devait une urgence jeudi même c'est
devenu une idée révolutionnaire elles
sont fragiles oui oui pas les imposer
par la force mais les régimes
despotiques sont pas si efficace que ça
maintenant regarder la mer il faut
renforcer la démonstration ça que le ni
ni et le non-alignement sont les grands
vainqueurs de ce qui est en train de se
passer hélas la population ukrainienne
en payent un prix très lourd
pascal boniface avant la conclusion 5
seulement effectivement bas l'occident
ne domine plus le monde il faut qu'ils
réalisent il faut que je le réalise
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
pascal boniface jean joseph boillot
dominique moïsi francis laloupo merci
ludovic ludovic de foucauld qui est avec
nous en direct d'istanbul merci à vous
tous deux hors si vous restez avec nous